i'm a big fan of time travel stories i
love the intricacies of paradoxes
the creation of different timelines or
if that's not the case
the changes to the single one that
exists the consequences the butterfly
effect
but most of all i love the internal
struggle that characters witness when
they go back in time
and the very visceral pain of being able
to witness a broken or
terrible past but because of the risk
having to hold yourself back from
changing it knowing
and accepting that you can't change the
past and looking towards a better future
that is the primary theme that makes
link click stand out to me
a new 2021 chinese anime that has truly
blown me away i'd say that i
i very much appreciate underrated anime
or underappreciated
rather hence my love for say space
brothers or mushishi or the recent odd
taxi which
like link click went largely under the
radar amidst spring 2021 anime
but while odd taxi is just an anime of
the season for me or maybe even the year
link click is even further along the
spectrum and has
genuinely stood out to me as what can
possibly become one of my all-time
favorite anime yeah
watch this show it follows two main
characters
the brains calm and collected lou guang
and the more headstrong and ambitious
forgive me for my pronunciation
who i'll refer to as chiang from now on
for the sake of the ears of
any chinese-speaking viewers right now
if you couldn't tell by the name it is a
donghua or a chinese
anime a category which in the past few
years has had a number of breakthroughs
in
mainstream anime the most notable being
the king's avatar
and i personally i'm rather ashamed to
say it i've never watched one before
so i figured now was the time to start
and whether this show is an
anomaly or a true representation of the
standard that dong will reach
this category of show has totally earned
my respect
it was simply that good now lu guang and
chang run a small shop called the time
photo studio that fronts
as a simple photo development store
however
their main job is traveling into photos
given by their clients for
various reasons to collect information
from someone's boss
say goodbye to a past lover they enter
photos into past memories of people and
look for information now lu guang is
able to see the 12 hour time frame
after the photo was taken the timeline
every moment that happens
he essentially becomes this omniscient
viewer
meanwhile chang enters the photo in the
body of the photo taker
lu guang constantly informs cheng of
what he has to do to make sure he
doesn't change the timeline at all
from ways he has to act to words he has
to say
all the while chang has to make sure he
does the job and collects whatever
information the client needs
the overall concept is rather simple at
surface level
enter the photo and do the task you need
to without changing
anything one of the lines lu guang the
common collected one always says
goes along the lines of we don't change
the past
for the sake of changing the future
and first i must mention the awesome
dynamic between lu guang
and chang aside from the very obvious
yin and yang
imagery of their hair they are really
just that
opposites that complete each other
without chang they can't enter photos
but without lu guang cheng would
inevitably change the timeline
completely
return to a life that he doesn't even
know
headstrong versus collected ambitious
verse reserved
and this dynamic this dichotomy
inevitably leads to
conflict because chang upon entering the
body of the photo taker
experiences their emotions as well
how they feel at the moment and should
the photo be steeped in tragedy then the
urge to change things
to make them better becomes stronger and
more difficult to avoid for the
headstrong chang but while this is the
makings for a rather annoying character
at surface level
being the one who can't follow the rules
and is constantly trying to change the
timeline
chang is actually done extremely well i
actually like him more than
lu guang it's hard to go into all of it
without spoiling but the combination of
him being
in the literal shoes of the characters
as well as the events he's put through
you really end up sympathizing with him
because in a way
he is the only one suffering here the
clients have already lived through these
memories
liu guang knows the events from start to
finish and how it should go
he's disconnected from the story but
chang
is the one who has to relive it
regardless of whether the
end to that 12 hour time frame is good
or bad
for lou guang it's just a job but for
chang
it's his life and someone else's that he
is embodying
and to go through that and accept a
terrible end is very difficult and
inevitably the idea of changing the past
becomes the central conflict of the show
again i have to reiterate for any time
travel buffs any steins gate fans or
vivi or re-zero
i think you'll love this show the time
travel is done
very well it's explained clearly without
having any holes that i noticed or
anything like that
the show itself aside from the central
concept is also just put together
very very well it's widescreen which
isn't often seen in anime honestly
i can personally only think of the
monogatari series off the top of my head
but in link click along with the great
animation and the wide screen
it works together to make this very
cinematic and artistic feel
to it visually the first episode has a
food making scene a staple of
any well animated movie like all
of the anime movies have it for some
reason i don't i don't even know why
and the animation just stays
consistently strong it never
falters i mean they even have a whole
episode where it's really just
chang playing basketball in someone
else's body and it's animated like
almost better than half the games in
kuroko basket
it is very very visually pleasing and
plus on my mandatory ost rant
the ost itself isn't necessarily top
tier it's good don't get me wrong
but the opening and ending are awesome
it's where the show
really shines sonically the opening is
this funky english track where the
characters are tutting it has like a
similar feel to jiu-jitsu tyson's ending
with real human-like dancing and the
song is great of course
and the ending is this dope chinese
hip-hop track that
always gets built up to at the end of
each episode
almost every episode ends on some kind
of dramatic note or cliffhanger
and the ending just eases right in
listen to this
but to return to that idea of link click
having a cinematic feel to it
even more than just aesthetically this
show is almost like
multiple movies put into a single series
each client or each photo that lu guang
and chen go into
feels like a single movie in itself it
tells a complete story through these
characters
pasts for example here i will briefly
discuss what happens in the side story
episode which is technically an add-on
to the 11 episode series so i'm trying
to avoid spoilers while making sure to
give you a
rather holistic view on what happens in
each episode
now here the two boys receive an image
from a man who loves this girl from a
strict martial arts family
and he can only marry her if he beats
her father in battle
despite him not being from a martial
arts family and the girl being older
than him
year after year he walks up the mountain
to their temple and
feudily fights her father now chen goes
into the photo to figure out the key to
beating him what the father's hidden
technique is
as he fights and lugung of course tells
him how to avoid the hits and survives
since
he knows what'll happen he feels the
perseverance and feelings of the man
towards his lover
what keeps pushing him year after year
and unfortunately it's revealed in the
past that there is in fact another man
who wishes to wed her
so this is our client's last chance
but chang couldn't figure it out he ends
the 12-hour time frame without ever
figuring out what it was
so after they leave the photo they
return to the man who they've never met
they got the photo without seeing him
only to realize now that the young man
who you expected to be just a year older
than said photo trying again
is in fact a man now well into his years
a father a grandfather even he never
once figured out how to win
but has run a dojo for years now because
he never gave up
and continues climbing those stairs
every year
it's heartbreaking and beautiful knowing
that this photo that he sent them was
was just a last-ditch effort that he's
tried all this time without ever knowing
how to win
and they take him up one last time to
the top of the mountain and
on second thought actually i won't spoil
the end just watch the show
but you can see how emotional link click
can get because the
entire premise is essentially using the
past to make
a better future and there actually is an
overarching plot that is drenched in
mystery and
intrigue that comes by every so often so
it's not just episodic if you don't like
that
i really can't can't praise this show
enough i might even make a more deep
philosophical type video about it once
it's finished and has time to marinate
in my mind
but i just had to get this out now
because i want to make sure that people
hear about it
i mean i don't even remember how i found
it yesterday afternoon but i couldn't
stop watching after i started
i feel like because it's an o a not
japanese it naturally goes under the
radar more
but but please give it a try
it is awesome it's emotional it's
dramatic and intense
and i just love it i've loved it since
the start and hopefully by the time it
finishes in two episodes
i'll love it to the very end what do you
guys think have have any of you watched
it
if so do you like it as much as i do you
might not i'm a big time travel guy and
animation so it really just hit all the
bases for me
leave a comment down below as always
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you